alors on reçoit ce soir donc je le
disais la mère de voisin le Bretonneux
sur tout le mois de janvier on reçoit
l'ensemble des maires de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines et une thématique on le
disait on commençait en parler en début
d'émission qui est bien et réelle pour
toutes les communes aussi pour
l'ensemble des Français c'est le de
l'explosion des coups on parle depuis
quelques mois aussi de du terme de
sobriété énergétique qui est l'une des
solutions pour faire face justement à
l'augmentation de ses coûts qu'est-ce
qui est vous prévoyez de faire dans
votre commune qu'est-ce qui a déjà été
fait à Voisins-le-Bretonneux alors où on
a été obligé effectivement de d'agir
donc on a en particulier réduit les
activités pendant les vacances donc dans
nos équipements sportifs et culturels on
a même fermé pendant les vacances de
Noël avec avec les associations que je
remercie parce que elles ont vraiment
fait preuve de responsabilité et en
février on va fermer une semaine sur les
sur les deux parce que les associations
doivent aussi faire des stages on des
compétitions etc on a blessé bien sûr la
température partout que ce soit dans nos
équipements publics dans les écoles pas
dans les crèches par contre pour le coup
là non et puis on éteint les lumières
bon ça c'est avec l'agglomération
puisque notre éclairage est
intercommunale voilà toutes les pistes
de d'économie évidemment sont mises en
oeuvre étudiés ça aussi ça guide aussi
nos choix budgétaires à venir puisque on
voit bien que le coût des fluides je
sais pas nous on a pris depuis 2021 on
est à plus 400% pour le gaz il y a plus
de 100% pour l'excès de l'électricité
les mesures d'urgence
en 2023 lors de de grands projets on va
parler des grands dossiers de voisins
breteux vous étiez venu nous parler d'un
autre dossier qui a été lancé ses
voisins 2035 c'est bien ça c'est en soi
imaginer que les habitants la commune
telle qu'elle sera dans une quinzaine
d'années est-ce que ça va se poursuivre
sur l'année 2023 cette réflexion oui
alors déjà l'as sens civique qui a mené
tout ce travail doit nous rendre son
récit partagé puisque le livrable
c'était un récit partagé donc ils vont
ça va être fait en début d'année et
probablement qu'il y a des thématiques
sur lesquelles on va pouvoir rebondir et
utiliser ce que les habitants nous ont
dit parce qu'on a une ville qui est
perpétuellement en transformation et en
mouvement et donc c'est important de
voilà de s'inspirer des
des idées des habitants pour avoir des
directions qui correspondent le plus
possible à leurs attentes justement il y
a la poursuite de ce chantier aussi en
2023 à Voisins-le-Bretonneux avec le
concours aussi de 50 en Yvelines c'est
cette ZAC de la remise cette zone
d'aménagement concerté les travaux ont
été lancés depuis l'an dernier alors
quelques chiffres un plus de 500
logements seront construits sur 10
hectares plusieurs équipements publics
et des commerces avec un objectif qui
était annoncé l'année dernière c'est des
premières livraisons dès l'année 2023 ce
qu'on pourra tenir cet objectif non dans
l'objectif c'est 2024 on parlait de
premier livraison fin 2023
de faire le quartier d'un seul tenant
pour d'abord créer le moins de nuisances
possible pour les riverains enfin que ça
dure le moins longtemps possible et
également pour que les tous les
promoteurs mutualisent et fassent des
économies qui leur réinjecte dans
quelques innovations donc pour l'instant
on va être première livraison fin de
premier trimestre 2024 et ça va s'étaler
sur toute l'année 2024 je précise juste
que les images que l'on vient de voir
c'était au début du chantier ça a bien
évolué depuis mais en tout cas on voit
des des vues d'artistes qui
a quelques griffes qui montrent ce à
quoi ressemblera cette ZAC de la remise
alors il y a une actualité aussi qui
avait fait grand bruit dans la commune
fin 2022 c'est une officialisation de la
fermeture de l'école du bois de la
Garenne et ce à la rentrée prochaine
juste rappeler pourquoi était nécessaire
de fermer cette école et parce que nous
avons une baisse du nombre d'élèves dans
d'abord sur toute la commune depuis
quelques années on a perdu plus de 1000
élèves en 15 ans on va dire donc c'est
aussi une baisse de la population c'est
toujours ensemble et
revoir la carte scolaire ne servait plus
à rien parce que tous les ans il y a des
classes qui ferment dans différents
groupes scolaires donc les parents sont
inquiétaient évidemment et donc revoir
la carte scolaire ne servait plus à rien
c'était déshabiller Pierre pour habiller
Jacques etc donc on a fait des études
sur l'état de nos bâtiments sur les
perspectives pour remplir nos écoles on
va dire il se trouve que cette école là
coche plusieurs cases c'est elle est
énergivore c'est pas la seule mais elle
est ramenée au nombre d'enfants c'est
une des plus énergivores les enfants
baissent de fois tous les ans et comme
nous sommes dans un quartier uniquement
pavillonnaire et bien où les pavillons
sont très chers il y a pas possibilité
de ramener de nouveaux enfants enfin en
tout cas de d'amener de nouveaux
habitants et
puis on a une école à un kilomètre qui
peut accueillir les enfants donc très
très bonne condition donc il faut un
moment que nous qu'on rationalise nos
équipements et j'ai envie de dire que la
crise énergétique que nous vivons nous
donne raison et en 2013 elle est
ancienne concertation pour décider
justement ce qui va devenir de ce site
tout à fait voilà c'est un engagement
que nous allons tenir nous allons
démarrer en mars une concertation avec
les habitants de la commune c'est pas un
projet de quartier c'est un projet pour
la commune c'est un terrain qui nous
appartient donc voilà on va pouvoir
discuter de nos besoins et puis
aboutir j'espère en juin au moins au
concept ou à l'idée de ce qu'on pourra y
mettre et ça mettra fin je dirais à
toutes les élucubrations qu'on peut
entendre ici et là ça s'est acté pour ce
nouvel équipement une nouvelle crèche
dans le quartier de la remise dès cette
année alors la crèche les travaux vont
commencer incessamment sous peu ce sera
une crèche une écolo crèche elle sera
labellisée
en plus sera chauffé la géothermie donc
là voilà on est très content d'avoir
fait ces choix là et donc travaux qui
débutent cette année
pour que les enfants y rentrent en
septembre 2024
60 berceaux pour pour cette crèche et
des projets qui se concrétisent aussi à
réaménagement du stade du Grand près ça
sera terminé dès cette année il y aura
notamment des cours de paddle alors
c'est 8 dis-moi de travaux donc là ça a
commencé en fait c'est un réaménagement
global dans lequel il y aura des
terrains de pétanque qui vont être un
peu rénovés parce que ils sont pas en
très bon état ensuite on aura une
couverture dans lequel il y aura un
espace de convivialité pour nos joueurs
de pétanque et puis il y aura également
deux terrains de paddle et puis à côté
de ça on refait également deux terrains
de tennis dont un qui accueillera les
vicinois gratuitement sans sans
réservation et les cours de paddle
seront gérés par le club de tennis mais
accessible au vie si noir d'accord et
très important c'est que nous mettons de
récolte des autres pluies
de cette ampleur voilà donc il y a une
cuve de récupération d'eau qui a été
placée là qui est déjà en place
qui nous permettra d'arroser l'été quand
on est en période de sécheresse de pas
mettre de faire aussi des économies de
ce point de vue là alors vu qu'on est
sur les équipements sportifs il y en a
un qui ne le sera plus bientôt c'est le
stade du champ du loup qui va devenir un
cimetière oui alors c'est beaucoup moins
gai évidemment mais c'était devenu
indispensable et incontournable puisque
le cimetière notre cimetière est
quasiment plein donc là les travaux on
espère vont commencer probablement en
avril et vont durer un petit peu moins
d'un an
ce sera ça a été un long travail parce
que beaucoup d'études de sol enfin c'est
très complexe un cimetière et ça prend
beaucoup de temps une problématique
aussi à voisins-le-breteux je me
souviens on en parlait sur les débats de
des municipales de l'année 2020 celle de
la circulation
c'est un carrefour un voisin de
Bretonneux on le rappelle entre 50 ans
en Yvelines la vallée de Chevreuse donc
beaucoup de de circulation est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre à des nouveautés sur le
plan de la circulation je crois qu'il y
a un travail qui va être mené avec 50
ans en Yvelines sur le sujet c'est mieux
que ça c'est-à-dire que là nous
travailler avec 50 années d'îles et le
département puisqu'on est sur une
départementale et donc là ça y est nous
avons acté donc il y a quatre Carrefour
qui vont être retravaillés réaménagés et
travaux vont débuter dès cette année
puis l'idée c'est de faire les travaux
avant les Jeux olympiques de l'année
prochaine qui vont passer par la course
cycliste va passer par là donc là nous
allons avoir des travaux importants qui
vont générer pas mal de nuisances mais
qui devraient permettre un petit peu de
à qui sont là pour permettre d'améliorer
la circulation
tout en préservant la sécurité
évidemment des piétons donc gros travaux
à prévoir sur 2023 mais c'était attendu
depuis très longtemps et on a fait un
travail enfin mes élus en tout cas en
charge de ça on fait un travail
extraordinaire voilà vous parlez de jeux
olympiques les étoiles dans les yeux de
notre journaliste sport Michaël Mido
j'avoue que j'en ai également avant cet
échéance olympique
des pyramides qui sont
un tournoi international de tennis de
table de para-tennis de table donc
tennis de table handisport qui a été
accueilli sur place donc ça se prépare
déjà un des cette année c'est échéance
ça se prépare et d'abord on a un club de
tennis de table qui est extrêmement
dynamique et qui a aussi été skipping
voilà skipping ça dépend
donc voilà donc on est très très content
on va accueillir des pongistes de Corée
du Sud je crois
et donc on attend c'est après c'est eux
qui décident quand est-ce qu'ils
viennent donc on est très content
Yvelines à inter olympique avec
plusieurs sites qui seront d'ailleurs
juste à côté de la communauté
Voisins-le-Bretonneux sur le site de
Guyancourt le Golf National et aussi ce
vélo de national à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il y en a
d'autres à Élancourt notamment il y aura
aussi des temps culturels à prévoir sur
cette année 2023 je crois qu'il y aura
une exposition sur l'histoire de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux on pourra
redécouvrir l'histoire de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux avec le
partenariat avec le musée de la ville on
fait une exposition sur l'histoire de
voisins et et puis on va implanter ils
sont prêts il y a plus qu'à les poser
des plats des panneaux qui vont retracer
un peu l'histoire des lieux parce que
voisins étaient un petit village avec
300 habitants et c'est devenu une petite
ville on va dire de maintenant on est
plus on a un petit peu moins de 11000
mais on est à monter à plus de 12000
habitants donc on veut redonner enfin
que les vicinois se rendent compte un
petit peu garde en mémoire je veux dire
ce passé rural
qui fait partie de nos racines les
dernières choses dans vos vœux vidéo
j'ai noté la date du 26 mars vous avez
annoncé un événement vous pouvez pas
nous en dire plus ça va être
extraordinaire donc
comment dire
on va avoir un musicien de renommer
mondial qui va venir qui va venir à
voisin qui était le qui allait je vais
vous le dire quand même c'était le
qui est le gendarmonica de Johnny et
donc on va avoir tout un événement
autour de ça avec des surprises et ça va
être une journée assez inédite à un
voisin le Bretonneux et on est
enthousiaste voilà
l'interview express
Alexandra Rosetti je vais vous poser 5
questions on pose les mêmes questions à
l'ensemble des maires qui viennent sur
sur ce plateau en janvier une exigence
des réponses courtes oui un nom un pour
ou contre parfois quelques explications
je vous demander ça n'excède pas 20 à 30
secondes pour pour ses explications
première question est-ce qu'en 2023 vous
augmenterez les impôts locaux dans votre
commune c'est en cours de simulation on
est en train de faire des calculs parce
que c'est on est dans une situation
compliquée à cause de tout ce qu'on a
dit à tout à l'heure notamment sur
l'explosion des coûts côté circulation
certaines communes ont fait le choix de
passer à une limitation de vitesse à 30
km/h dans dans leur commune est-ce que
dans le centre-ville de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux c'est envisageable
mais ce que vous êtes pour ou contre une
telle mesure je suis pas spécialement
pour mais on parce que je pense qu'il
faut une hiérarchie des vitesses mais on
travaille sur des zones à 30 voilà mais
pas forcément toute la commune certaines
communes ont aussi fait le choix du bio
pour leur cantine vous êtes pour ou
contre une obligation dans les dans les
cantines en termes de bio une incitation
peut-être je suis une rebelle par
principe je suis contre les obligations
même si je peux pour le bio évidemment
mais un petit peu marre des obligations
qui nous tombe dessus et qui nous
mettent des fois en difficulté on a vu
malheureusement certains maires certains
élus victimes d'agressions ou de menaces
est-ce que dans l'exercice de vos
fonctions où vous êtes déjà senti menacé
une fois dernière question est-ce que
vous êtes une mère heureuse oui oui je
suis une mère
heureuse et une mère aussi tout va bien
merci Alexandra Rosetti vous allez jouer
le jeu de ces réponses courtes mère de
Voisins le bretonneux et très bonne
année 2023 dans votre commune